ich will das Wort klimakriminelle hier
sehr sehr bewusst denn die Klima Kleber
geben für mich viel zu weit ich finde ja
dass allein dieses Wort die Aktivitäten
dieser Bewegung verniedlicht Klima
Kleber erinnert mich immer an ein
Aktivitäten Kindergarten mit roten
Buntstift und grünen Bäumen wo
klimazeichnung aufgeklebt werden wir
müssen sie endlich als das bezeichnen
was sie sind Kriminelle denn wer Straßen
blockiert indem er sich an den Boden
klebt hilft nicht dem Klima sondern
gefährdet Menschenleben wie es jetzt
gerade hier in Berlin leider passiert
ist die ökoextremisten haben durch eine
klebeblockade auf der Stadtautobahn ein
Stau verursacht und so die Rettung einer
Schwerverletzten gefährdet ein dringend
benötigtes Spezialfahrzeug konnte nicht
rechtzeitig zu der Radfahrerin gelangen
jetzt kämpft die Frau um ihr Leben
solange unsere Politik auf dem linken
und dem grünen Auge blind ist und sie
verharmlosen so wie du das gesagt hast
werden sie weitermachen sich animiert
fühlen ich sage es reicht das sind
Kriminelle wir Menschen Leben gefährdet
gehört ins gef